Hello Freak bitches.
So you've got to quash sex because the and,
and gluttony because those are reminders that were just primates for meanwhile
the depictions of God,
he's always ripped.
He's always,
he's always wearing a robe cause he's modest.
He's reaching over and touching people.
His fingers go,
he's got giant traps and what's great,
it's true.
God looks awesome as his son.
It sounds looking sons on great on the Cross,
beaten to death half and he's got abs and really watch for a guy who was for a
guy,
was living in the Middle East 2000 years ago,
but skin bronze,
hair of wool bullshit.
They uh,
the other possibility of a black planet,
Chuck d was right.
Degas that look at that.
But God beautiful.
The dude on the left hind a little dot on the dude.
That's what I'm saying.
Not even,
I mean,
why even draw it?
You might as well just make him an alien with no genitals.
People back then just had little or dicks.
Is that possible?
It's possible,
but I've always just assumed that that it's the modesty of the artists like it.
It kind of changed the frame of the picture of God reaching down and touching
men.
If men had a massive schlong just hanging down his leg.
Yeah,
it would be distracting if you're just giant John Holmes hard,
but look how big the muscles are in these guys.
Like these guys have to be fucking crossfitting all day as well as being divine.
I mean,
that guy on the left is doing a lot of fucking weightlifting.
There is not a regular body that's a body of someone who's picking up heavy shit
all day long,
but he's got a skinny neck.
I bet he's never been choked.
Maybes and act.
That's not a guy who knows how to cut out of a choke.
No Little Dick Skinny neck,
but giant fucking biceps.
Leave his forearms.
It does a lot of,
there's a lot of weightlifting for sure.
Michelangelo's ceiling of the Sistine Chapel and look at the bizarre image of
God being supported by Cherubs.
How weird people are religion it.
See got Dick though.
Notice that.
Nope,
he's got a robot and then other dummy showing his little tiny dick.
God looks kind of,
I haven't really noticed this before,
but God on the ceiling of the Sistine Chapel looks a bit like Meryl Streep,
Meryl Streep with a bead cause I think he's kind of got breasts and he's,
he's wearing like a nice white robe
now.
It's to a guy like you,
Google auto drive cars have to be the devil.
Yes.
That's the devil.
It is.
What's going to happen?
Are we going to,
we're going to not be able to drive our own cars in the future.
Is that a possibility?
You know,
I've been thinking long and hard about that and it's been something that um,
different people and um,
my sub culture have openly been concerned and discussing and there's many
different takes on it.
But I think I'm pretty centered on it.
I think actually it's a positive thing and that Carl is like the Prius and
stuff,
you know,
started the generation where people don't have an emotional relationship with
their vehicle.
It's a tool.
It's literally like an APP on your phone.
It gets you from a to B or even more dispassionately,
screw it.
You Uber around and you don't care.
You don't have that relationship.
So I think culturally as autonomous vehicles and all that continued to grow and
evolve,
you are going to see them eventually become predominant and I think we're going
to start to see lobbying and federal support of that direction because there's a
lot of rational reasons behind it.
That being said,
I think it will further strengthen the demand for the freaks and the Geeks,
the outliers such as my brand because people are going to yearn for that
relationship,
that attachment,
and I think there's always going to be people,
even the guy who's got the autonomous Mercedes at that,
his computer,
but on the week it's like,
oh no,
I mean this thing's got a,
it's called a manual transmission and there's,
there's,
there's pedals by the way,
and there's three of those pedals and you have to push that one down to get it
too.
But you know,
I think there,
there's that visceral relationship that is always going to be part of mankind
and I'm not worried about it.
If I was trying to start a big car company,
then I would be worried about it.
This is,
this is difficult thought and is a difficult subject,
but did you,
after this was all said and done a horrendous moment in your life,
many moments in your life,
did you try to figure out what would create a person like the guy who did that
to you?
Did you try how much time?
Yeah,
and I can tell you what created him.
He was taken out of an abusive home.
He was put into foster care and abused many more times and he was gone and he
was gone and it was gone and he was succumbed by the agony I was put through by
him.
I survived.
Somehow I made it so call me lucky.
I'm not,
I didn't become him.
I didn't become what I resisted.
I didn't,
I didn't pass along the poison.
Maybe I did in some ways when I was difficult or whatever,
but mostly I didn't.
Mostly when I'm mad,
I'm mad because it's like Hendrix,
a cry of love.
It's a cry of love that I make.
It's a cry of love.
My Act has been a cry of love.
It's like I don't want the innocent hurt anymore.
I don't want people victimized because of greed and cower to some bullshit,
you know?
I don't want that.
And so I,
I do what I can to stand up to it to,
were there moments where you wanted to talk to him?
What do you want to talk to him?
I would love to talk to him to show him that I'd been,
didn't become a monster like he was.
I W I would have,
I would have almost become an advocate for him in the sense that like,
well mate,
you let me know if they're mistreating you in here.
But he died in prison.
No one claimed his body and I don't know where his grave is.
If I knew her as grave,
it was like go put fucking flowers on it.
Not for him.
For me.
So the Solomon asch conformity study was framed to people coming into it as a
visual perception experiment.
Basically,
they'd be brought into a room with several people in a semi circle
and there'll be a person in the front with a card with four lines on it,
a sample line,
and then three other lines of different sizes.
Okay,
let's say a three and simple line,
a three inch or four inch and a five inch,
but everyone is in on the experiment except the person and seat six and after
going around twice giving the correct answer,
everyone confidently starts giving the wrong same answer.
And the test is how many people will start to conform to giving the wrong
answer,
even though they can see what their own eyes,
what the correct answer is.
And that study's been replicated thousands of times and the answer is two thirds
start giving the wrong answer even though they know intellectually that it's the
wrong answer because it feels too uncomfortable to be in the room.
And is that the,
the,
the testimony that they give when they are asked,
what did they,
I'm sure assuming the interview these people absolutely.
Yeah,
I say it's uncomfortable and I even show a date line and old dateline episode
where they asked Anthony Pratt,
Kansas is one of the foremost social psychologists to to actually do the study
so they could film it and this,
they start out with this Asian woman who is the her role at resistor who gives
the correct answer but she's grimacing and she's giving the wrong answer even
though she knows it's the right answer.
But because of the social forces we are have mirror neurons,
we want to fit in to the people in the room.
It's just human nature.
How people survive.
Exactly.
Clan behave.
Exactly,
but it's hard wired.
So I showed that video that that experiment and I always like to ask people,
so tell me a,
something you could do if you were in that situation to scientifically reality
test that situation.
Scientifically reality testing meaning meaning one,
you're in this room.
Everyone's saying a five inch line is a three inch line.
What could you do?
Let me ask you,
what would you do?
Because you have the data now.
Okay,
you're,
you're a cult expert.
You would get up and measure it.
Right?
But you would have obviously understand what's going on.
Right,
exactly.
But if you asked me prior to my induction into the moonies that I understand the
asch conformity study or the power of B,
I would have said,
no,
I'm an individual.
I'm a nonconformist.
I had the bumper sticker question authority,
and I had the pony tail.
And you know the word unique
fit right in you rebel
[inaudible].